setting out at Daybreak members of Sri
Lanka is Maliah Community walked the
path taken by their ancestors 200 years
ago
also called Plantation tamils or up
country tamils thousands of people were
brought to the island from South India
to work on coffee tea and rubber
plantations
74 year old murugan ganeshan the oldest
of the group told Al Jazeera how his
grandparents remembered the journey
when they arrived there were no roads
they had to cut through the jungle they
didn't have enough food and some died
along the way the survivors couldn't
bury them they were also wild animals
and some people were attacked and killed
believed to be from lower costs the
Malaya tamos did not own land and many
were poor
they dreamed of a better life across the
sea
but the reality was exploitation and
hardship long hours in the fields
activists say the community made a major
contribution to Sri Lanka's economic
development but has never been
recognized
we were disenfranchised for decades we
were made stateless for decades and
there had been you know rather than
being treated as Citizens we were
treated more as workers continuously
what we want is that to change and this
March is about that Gotham and
balakrishnan himself a Malaya Tamil says
members of the community are determined
to change the historic structural
exclusion of their people
they weren't aware of their rights there
was no one to teach them because they
weren't educated if today's youth can
pass on what we know we can make sure
this doesn't happen again
we are remembering our forefathers by
retracing their steps to understand the
hardships and sacrifices they made for
us
despite earning the country millions of
dollars in foreign exchange these
workers are paid just more than three
dollars a day Plantation Tamil should be
celebrated for their vital role in
making Ceylon tea a global brand instead
the community is the poorest in the
country with some of the lowest Health
Nutrition and education indicators 200
years on change is still elusive
Fernandez Al Jazeera marthalay Central
Sri Lanka